hey guys i'm at the hospital right now  i'm fine i've got an ng tube in my nose  right now which drains stuff out of my  stomach because i have a  small intestine blockage  i've had this before if you remember in  2015 or  something like that 2016. so i've been  through this  but i uh man  this is uh unexpected came out of  nowhere but i'm fine  it's nothing life-threatening um i don't  even think i'm gonna need surgery this  time  they're just gonna suck it out of me and  hopefully that fixes the problem  but i'm gonna be out of commission for a  few days so when i get back  you know content will resume but in the  meantime  it's another markiplier hospital vid i  got to make a playlist about these now  once i get to a certain amount i gotta  do it  anyway i'm probably gonna go to sleep  soon it's  it's late and i'm very tired and  ready to become one  with the ng tube  see around guys i'll let you know if  anything changes bye